>> IMAGES OF THAT THEY ARE.
KRISTIN FISHER LIVE FROM THE
NORTH LAWN.
AS KRISTIN JUST MENTIONED,
JOE BIDEN IS PROMISING THAT
GUIDE AMERICA OUT OF WHAT HE
CALLS THE SEASON OF DARKNESS.
BUT HE MAY BE HAVING TROUBLE
CONVINCING SOME OF THE
PROGRESSIVES IN HIS OWN PARTY
THAT HE HAS SEEN THE LIGHT.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
REPORTS TONIGHT FROM WILMINGTON,
DELAWARE,.
>> THIS IS HOW JOE BIDEN PITCHED
HIMSELF IN A SPEECH HE HAS
WAITED DECADES TO GIVE.
>> I WILL BE AN ALLY OF THE
LIGHT COMING OUT THE DARKNESS.
JUST OUTSIDE, HORNS HONKED AND
HEAD LIGHTS FLASHED HAS INVITED
GUESTS WATCH THE DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE FORMALLY ACCEPT THE
NOMINATION THEM A SOCIALLY
DISTANCED FROM THEIR CARS.
THE MORNING AFTER, A FIRST ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, A GOLF CART
PARADE FOR JOE BIDEN AT THE
VILLAGES IN FLORIDA.
ALL WEEK CONVENTION ORGANIZER
TRIED TO PROJECT HARMONY AMONG
MODERATES AND PROGRESSIVES BUT
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
PROGRESSIVE SPEAKERS WAS NEVER
ACTUALLY ASKED BY CONVENTION
ORGANIZERS TO APPEAR AND ONLY
HAD TIME IN THE SHOW BECAUSE
BERNIE SANDERS ASKED HER TO SEC
AND NOMINATION.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
>> WITH THE DNC IS SAYING IS SHE
SPEAKING.
NO, THEY SHOULD HAVE.
THAT’S A WHOLE OTHER STORY.
>> SANDERS WAS ALL SMILES WITH
FORMER RIVALS.
>> INVITED MY GIRLFRIEND LIKE
YOU MORE THAN SHE LIKED ME?
>> BUT WAS ULTIMATELY PLEASED
RUDE >> THEY SHOULD HAVE HAD
MORE PROGRESSIVE SPEAKING.
>> MANY SPEAKERS INCLUDING THE
NOW NOMINEE DEVOTED SIGNIFICANT
TIME TO ATTACKING
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> THE PRESIDENT KEEPS TELLING
US THE VIRUS IS GOING TO
DISAPPEAR.
HE KEEPS WAITING FOR A MIRACLE.
I HAVE NEWS FOR HIM, NO MIRACLE
IS COMING.
>> REPUBLICAN CRITICS SAY ALL
THE TRUMP TALK LEFT SOME
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PLATFORM.
>> SPENT FOUR DAYS IN A
CONVENTION AND I DON’T KNOW ONE
THING THAT’S ON THEIR AGENDA
EXCEPT THEY DISLIKE THIS
PRESIDENT AND THEY’RE GOING TO
RAISE YOUR TAXES.
>> ONE OF THE CLOSING NIGHTS
MOST MOVING MOMENTS CAME FROM A
NEW HAMPSHIRE TEENAGER.
>> I’M 13 YEARS OLD.
WITHOUT JOE BIDEN, I WOULDN’T BE
TALKING TO YOU TODAY.
>> MET INVITED IN FEBRUARY
ASKING ADVICE ABOUT SOMETHING
JOE BIDEN STRUGGLED WITH AS A
YOUNG MAN.
>> YOU WILL SEE THIS KID BECOME
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA SOMEDAY.
>> HE HAD A GLOBAL PLATFORM.
>> KIDS LIKE ME ARE COUNTING ON
YOU TO ELECT SOMEONE WE CAN ALL
LOOK UP TO.
>> NOW THE REST IS UP TO BIDEN.
>> I WILL BE AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT.
>> JUST 15 MINUTES AGO, A
BRAND-NEW BIDEN INTERVIEW
CONDUCTED THIS AFTERNOON HERE IN
WILMINGTON DROPPED, ABC NEWS
ASKED HIM IF HE WOULD SHUT THE
COUNTRY DOWN DURING A COVID
SPIKE HAVE THAT WAS WHAT
SCIENTISTS RECOMMENDED AND
SAYING "I WOULD SHUT IT DOWN.
I WOULD LISTEN TO THE
SCIENTISTS."
AND THAT REPRESENTS ANOTHER
CLEAR-CUT DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
BIDEN AND TRUMP ABOUT ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT VOTERS CARE ABOUT